- Hello aspiring teachers,
Sal here from the
not-for-profit Khan Academy.
And all of us at Khan Academy and ETS
makers of the Praxis Core Exam recognize
that teachers are the most essential part
of a learning experience
and that's why today
we're excited to announce
the launch of Official Praxis Core Prep
from Khan Academy and ETS to
truly level the playing field
and broaden the pipeline of
teachers throughout the country.
Aspiring teachers are going to be able
to come to Khan Academy, get diagnostics,
and work on math, reading, and writing,
and understand what your gaps are
and the software will adapt to allow you
to work on what will be
highest leverage for you
to prepare for the Praxis Core and beyond.
This is completely free,
it is not for profit
and we're confident that if
we give you this little help
that you'll be able to run with it
and impact generations
of students to come.